you dance moms are so predictable and
the longer you appear on Dance Moms the
more predictable you get Christy we know
you can't take it when Khloe gets
criticized but do you always have to
blow up before Abby finishes her
sentence and Holly why do you look so
painfully worried every single time Nia
steps out on the stage we've picked up
on your habits and filming mistakes and
we're about to put them on display it's
so easy to get distracted by all of the
drama on Dance Moms but if you dig a
little deeper you'll surely start to
notice a handful of things that most
people miss watch until the end and let
us know how many of these things you
noticed and how many of them you missed
[Applause]
same costume different solo coming up
with new and improved costumes every
single week can be downright impossible
this is especially true considering that
many of the Dance Moms had to fabricate
their own costumes did any of you notice
that Maddie was wearing the exact same
costume for her angel and Manhattan
solos costume mishap once again we're on
the subject of costumes but this time
we're looking at Mackenzie not Maddie
during the winters war performance
Maddie twirled Kenzie around and a piece
of her costume fell off the girls didn't
seem to notice but some eagle-eyed fans
immediately saw the white ribbon fall
off of Kenzie's dress Holly's facial
expressions watching your daughter
perform onstage can be a whole lot of
fun but when it comes to Holly it's safe
to assume that it's a stressful ordeal
everytime Nia has a solo
Holly watches from the audience with the
exact same look on her face her lips are
pursed into an O and her hands are held
up in a praying motion
like her Kelly's crazy eyes but Holly
isn't the only dance mom who gets a
strange look on her face while her
daughter is performing a solo have you
ever noticed I Kelly gets a classic case
of the crazy eyes every time she watches
Brooke and Paige perform say what you
want about Kelly
but her daughters are her pride and joy
last-second wardrobe changes in season
four Kinsey's outfit went from put
together to lacking before our very eyes
during rehearsals Kenzie is seen wearing
long black gloves but when she performs
her number
love overdose the gloves are nowhere to
be found we wonder why she chose to
ditch the gloves Maddie beat Kamryn
Maddie's been winning solo titles since
she was a little kid so it came as no
surprise when she won first place in
season two episode 20 but what did come
as a surprise was seeing Kamryn in the
background turns out that Maddie and
Cameron were competing for the same
title and Maddie won by a landslide
surprise surprise
superstitious Maddie it's no secret that
the cast of Dance Moms is a little
superstitious the girls had a special
handshake that they would perform before
going out on stage as well as a few
favorite lucky numbers but when it came
to scoring solos Maddie took things to
the next level solo did any of you
notice how Maddie crossed her fingers
before Abby announced the week's soloist
pyramid swap pyramid days are tough for
everyone but apparently they're so tough
that Abby has a hard time keeping track
of who goes where despite Kalani being
placed at the bottom of the pyramid and
Jojo being placed in the middle row the
girls pictures get swapped by the end of
the scene who else noticed this pyramid
day mistake tell us in the comments
reusing costumes remember when we said
that Maddie used the exact same costume
while performing Manhattan and angel
well she did it again during the group
dance frost you can clearly see that
Maddie is wearing the exact same white
outfit in season 4 episode 13 we wonder
how many times Maddie actually reused
that classic look Kendall and
background it's common knowledge that no
one is supposed to be on the stage
except for those who are performing well
it looks like Kendall missed this lesson
because we clearly see her on stage
during the mini mimes performance in
season 6 episode 27 Kendall only appears
for a few seconds but her braids are
super recognizable the producers
misspelled Kendall's name here's
something that not a lot of people
noticed during Kendall's bring on the
boys solo you would think that the
producers of Dance Moms would dot their
i's and cross their TS but during this
episode they totally forgot the second L
in Kendall's name we wonder if Kendall
herself is aware of this typo two places
at the same time it's no secret that the
producers of Dance Moms alter their
footage to make it look that much more
dramatic do you guys remember when vivvy
said the wrong Studios name in season 1
episode 3 well there's evidence of
footage tampering in this episode thanks
to Mackenzie at first she's on the stage
with vivvy
but when we see Abby's reaction to
Vivi's mistake Kenzie is in the audience
Jill's the worst and best dance mom if
there's one thing Dance Moms fans have
noticed it's that Jill is the biggest
hypocrite and instigator of all the
Dance Moms what genre is it anyway the
show's producers made another mistake in
season 3 when they labeled Kenzie solo
as contemporary during rehearsals Abby
made it clear that kindy solo was
acrobatic Abby gets taken aback if you
thought that Abby wasn't scared of
anything you were wrong turns out she's
scared of minister dawn but we can't say
we really blame her look at how Abby
Jones went on yells at her from behind
and that's a wrap let us know what your
score is down below thanks for watching
the things be sure to give this video a
big thumbs up and don't forget to hit
that subscribe button see you next time
[Music]